It might come as a surprise to find that
there are a whole bunch of free movies
available to watch on YouTube — and it
might come as an even bigger surprise
to find that some of them are actually
great. Here are a few of the very best.
In 1986, John Carpenter broke the cinematic
mold with Big Trouble in Little China,
a satirical kung fu movie that sets Kurt
Russell down in a labyrinthine Chinatown,
and leads him through an intriguing plot
involving kidnapping and sorcery. Unfortunately,
Big Trouble in Little China bombed at
the box office on release, making back
only around $11.1 million of its budget, which
has been estimated at roughly $20 million.
In fact, it bombed so badly that it drove
Carpenter away from Hollywood altogether.
But over the years, the film's reputation has
increased, and it's now considered a bona fide
cult classic. Empire magazine rated it
among the top 500 movies of all time,
and many of its vocal defenders praise it for its
skewering of stereotypical Asian roles in movies.
At the time, it was rare for a Western movie
even to feature a predominantly Asian cast.
As actor James Hong has said:
"There will never be another Big Trouble
in Little China. [...] Martial artists,
the greatest of all, actors, writers, [in]
that movie, John gave us all a chance."
There's never a bad time to watch The
Terminator, James Cameron's spectacular
1984 sci-fi action movie about time
travel, killer robots, and romance.
In case you somehow don't know the premise,
Sarah Connor is an ordinary young woman whose
life is suddenly upended when she turns out to be
the target of a Terminator - a cyborg sent from
the future to destroy her before she can sire the
son who will lead humanity against the machines.
Luckily for her, someone else has
come from the future: Kyle Reese,
a soldier sent to protect both Sarah
and humanity's hope for victory.
"Come with me if you wanna live."
Groundbreaking, intense,
and incredibly fun to boot,
The Terminator fully deserves the praise
heaped on it by Variety, who called it:
"A blazing, cinematic comic book, full of
virtuoso moviemaking, terrific momentum,
solid performances and a compelling story."
And the best part of all? Once you're
done with this one, you'll have a whole
franchise of Terminator movies, shows,
comics, and video games to explore.
Author Walter Tevis' stories are having a bit of
a renaissance these days, mostly thanks to the
breakout success of the wildly successful Netflix
adaptation of his novel The Queen's Gambit.
So now's as good a time as any to enjoy an equally
powerful adaptation of one of his other stories.
Martin Scorsese's The Color of Money is
a "25 years later" sequel to The Hustler,
with Paul Newman reprising his role from
the original. Newman plays Fast Eddie,
a former pool hall hustler who starts
mentoring Vincent, an up-and-coming player.
There's no way to do a belated sequel and please
everybody, even if you're Martin Scorsese,
but this is still the film that finally
got Paul Newman his well-deserved Best
Actor win at the Oscars. The cast is the
strongest selling point here: Sheila Benson,
writing for the Los Angeles Times,
describes the core players a,
quote, "an electrifying unholy trio."
Throw in a great soundtrack and some
typically brilliant direction from Scorcese, and
you've got the recipe for a genuine must-watch.
Let Me In is the English-language version
of the Swedish movie Let the Right One In,
and it actually achieves the incredibly difficult
task of living up to the original. In fact,
plenty of critics even argue that Let Me In is the
better film. Horror site Bloody Disgusting said:
"[Director Matt] Reeves takes a bold (and
dangerous) step in (basically) doing a
shot-for-shot remake of the Swedish vampire
flick, but finds a way to season it with a
little more emotion and flavor. Yes, I
said it, Let Me In is a BETTER movie."
Meanwhile, Stephen King called it
the best horror film of the decade,
and Rolling Stone's Peter Travers said:
"Prepare to be wowed. It's a spellbinder."
High praise all around. So what's it all about?
Well, Let Me In is a quiet, unsettling study of
the friendship that develops between Owen, a
bullied young boy, and an otherworldly young
girl named Abby. Things get much creepier and much
darker from there, but it'd be a shame to give
away too much. All you need to know is that Let
Me In is beautifully made and basically impossible
to look away from - and more than justifies
all the praise it attracted from critics.
Tune into the beginning of an epic franchise
with the original Stargate, the 1994 sci-fi
film starring Kurt Russell and James Spader. This
movie would eventually result in a sprawling set
of TV series, which ran for a combined total of
17 seasons, and a whole host of tie-in novels.
But it all started out relatively modestly, with a
standalone film about an expedition going through
a Stargate to a distant planet, discovering aliens
who once came to Earth and posed as Egyptian gods.
Spader plays Daniel Jackson, a civilian
linguist, and Russell is Colonel Jack O'Neil,
an Air Force officer who is more than
okay with this being a suicide mission.
The film got a rocky critical
reception on release.
In fact, Roger Ebert hated it so much that
he included it in a 2005 round-up of his most
hated films. But it got a few kinder notices
too, including one review from MovieLine,
which described it as, quote, "an instant
camp classic"; that is, the good kind of bad.
"How ya doing?"
And of course, at the time no one could
see the kind of mark it would eventually
leave on the TV landscape. It really
is the little sci-fi film that could.
2008's Slumdog Millionaire probably needs
no introduction. Featuring a star director
in Danny Boyle and a star lead in Dev
Patel, this movie was a huge success,
first on the festival circuit and then
at the box office. It even went on to
win an incredible eight Academy Awards,
including Best Picture and Best Director.
And, of course, it has a terrific hook. The
film tells the life story of Jamal Malik,
a poor young man who has had
an unexpected and thrilling
victory on the Indian version of
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire?,
not missing a single question. Now he has to tell
his life story to prove he came by the answers
honestly. Described by CinemaBlend as a story of
coincidence, luck, and eventually fate, Slumdog
Millionaire isn't so much a strict retelling of
events as it is, as the Los Angeles Times says:
"A Hollywood-style romantic
melodrama that delivers major
studio satisfactions in an ultra-modern way."
Of course, the film isn't above criticism,
especially in India - a country which some
have argued the movie misrepresents. Whether
you fall for the magic or just roll your eyes,
however, Slumdog Millionaire is still bound
to be a heck of a conversation-starter.
The 2004 documentary Super Size Me chronicles
Morgan Spurlock's ambitious - and unusual - quest
to eat nothing but McDonald's for every meal for
a month, in order to better understand the effects
of fast food on the human body. And it should
go without saying, but: Don't try this at home.
Still, as much as no one wants to see
Spurlock vomiting in a parking lot,
Super Size Me is funny, riveting,
and thought-provoking, to boot.
It's very easy to take issue with the validity
of Spurlock's experiment, but it's hard to
argue with the hugely entertaining film
that results. As Empire magazine says:
"It's a hugely enjoyable descent into epic
gluttony. It's the thinking man's Jackass."
Moulin Rouge! is wonderfully
and unabashedly overblown,
from its swoon-worthy romance to its gorgeously
artificial sets and its exuberant musical numbers.
The story follows Christian, an aspiring
young writer living in a garret in Paris.
When he meets Satine, a courtesan and star
performer at the Moulin Rouge cabaret,
the two fall in love at first sight. But Satine
needs to be practical - she's promised to the
weaselly Duke, who has invested heavily in the
Moulin Rouge's new show... which Christian is
supposed to write. It's a tangled web of desire,
secrets, danger, heartbreak, and can-cans.
In the movie itself, the artists of the Moulin
Rouge promise that the new show will leave its
audience "dumb with wonderment," and that's
exactly the effect of Moulin Rouge! itself.
Entertainment Weekly sums it up well, saying:
"Baz Luhrmann's trippy pop
culture pastiche from 2001
[is] an aesthetically arresting ode
to poetry, passion, and Elton John."
If that sounds at all like
something you would like,
well, then - Moulin Rouge!
was pretty much made for you.
Even if you haven't seen Ghost in the Shell,
you've probably seen Ghost in the Shell.
This cyberpunk noir anime, centering on a
cyborg government agent investigating a hacker,
has exerted a huge influence
on science fiction movies.
For example, when the Wachowskis saw it,
their pitch for The Matrix finally gelled:
they screened the movie for prospective producers
and announced that they wanted to do it for real.
“Woah.”
James Cameron, who is also one of the film's
many admirers, borrowed a little from it in
making Avatar, while Steven Spielberg did
the same with AI: Artificial Intelligence.
It really was a perfect storm of stunning visuals,
high-concept ideas, and futuristic speculation.
And, as one of the breakout anime movies
in the West, it remains a terrific
gateway into the form. Reel Rundown gives
it an enthusiastic recommendation, saying:
"As deep as its wonderful animation and
posing lots of philosophical questions,
Ghost in the Shell is a world-class piece of
science fiction that is uniquely Japanese and
utterly irresistible... dark, brooding and adult."
If you've ever found yourself curious about
anime, there's no better place to start than this.
2008's Traitor is a gripping, tense thriller
that, thanks to its casting of Don Cheadle and
Guy Pearce, now has the benefit of feeling
like a very weird Iron Man 3 reunion.
The movie dives straight into a thicket of
moral dilemmas and high-stakes conflicts.
Cheadle plays Samir Horn, a Sudanese-American man
who seems to be engaging in some murky dealings;
so naturally FBI Agent Roy Clayton suspects him of
terrorism. But this is more than a cat and mouse
game: It's really a kind of character study
that acts as a vehicle for Cheadle's superb
performance. Even critics who found the politics
clumsily handled or the twists implausible agree
that it's hard to look away from the movie's
star. A.O. Scott of The New York Times wrote:
"Cheadle's performance gives Traitor
a sense of ethical gravity and real
intrigue. [...] Somehow the character
retains his credibility even as the movie,
perhaps inevitably, trips over some of
its own complexities and confusions."
If you can allow for a slightly messy plot
as long as a film is ambitious enough - and
has a damn fine lead performance - then
Traitor is bound to glue you to your seat.
Sometimes cult classics are weird, challenging
movies that could never have found a mainstream
audience… and sometimes they're adorably silly
rom-com sports movies. Take The Cutting Edge,
for example; the endearing early '90s movie
about a prima donna figure and the former ice
hockey star who becomes her new skating partner.
The movie has plenty of loyal fans who are more
than capable of summing up its sunny appeal.
In their review for the movie, Decider wrote:
"At its core, The Cutting Edge is an endlessly
rewatchable, immensely enjoyable film that not
only understands but embraces the fact
that rom-coms are supposed to be fun."
And Fansided agreed too, saying:
"[The movie is] like a fine wine [...]
[it] has gotten better with age."
And sure, it's not exactly Citizen Kane -
but not every movie has to be a classic.
Sometimes all you need is a little
romance... and a whole lot of cheese.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.